welcome back the preparations are in
place for next week's big press
conference
president biden will hold his first
formal news conference since taking
office
biden is behind recent past presidents
who all had a news conference
within 33 days of taking office so
what's the holdup
and will biden take any tough questions
when he finally faces reporters
joining us right now is fox news
contributors michael goodwin and joe
concha
great to see you gentlemen so happy to
have you here uh
joe what do you think what are you
expecting this upcoming week
oh boy well to review what you just said
by the way uh president trump
held five news conferences both solo and
joint at this point
president obama two george w bush three
bill clinton five
joe biden 0.0 so what do i expect i
expect a few lids along the way
to this press conference because you
remember in september alone to prep for
a debate
uh joe biden took 12 lids in one month
for that
but here's the thing joe biden is at his
worst when he has to handle questions
extemporaneously in other words without
a teleprompter without
any sort of script and it has not helped
maria that he's like a boxer
going into a match without having
sparred against anybody or even trained
for that matter because you see these
events time and again where he's being
whisked out of a room
reporters are shouting questions his
communication team is saying
no more questions please leave so this
is going to be very interesting it's
going to be a big challenge for the
press as well
maria because look all eyes are on this
right now and not just the country
but our adversaries china russia iran
they see a 78 year old president who's
being largely hidden from the press
and the public in general and they want
to see exactly who they're dealing with
besides the guy they see reading a
teleprompter to this point
yeah i mean look i think you make great
points and michael i read your op-ed
that
this morning it was a great op-ed in the
new york post
bubble biting clearly not up for tough
questions or the job i'll also point out
something i saw today that is joe biden
went home to wilmington delaware again
today
so he's going home for the fourth time
since taking office sleeping at home in
delaware one day before this press
conference
your expectations for this press
conference next week
michael well my expectations are low and
that's part of the problem here for some
of the reasons that joe
detailed but the reality is maria that
this has been a very consequential
presidency already
we see what's going on with the border
you're talking about the meetings with
the chinese the iranian deal that he's
playing with and of course the 1.9
trillion dollar
stimulus package and all of the things
they're talking about trying to ram
through the senate maybe do away with
the filibuster
so there are a lot of things to ask joe
biden and the fact that
reporters have not been able to raises
the stakes on this moment
and i suspect that we will be
disappointed because i think the
questions will be pre-selected
and just as they've been doing all along
they'll go to the friendly reporters
i think biden prefers george
stephanopoulos when he wants to have an
interview
uh because he's guaranteed a friendly
audience stephanopoulos basically is a
democratic agent with a press pass
and so i think that that's the nature of
what we're seeing coming up here
with uh this press conference i'm afraid
we won't learn
very much important but we will get a
sense of whether joe biden can actually
string together answers on complicated
topics well i mean what are the
implications of all of this joe
the implications are that by waiting
this long right nine weeks
there's a lot of to michael's point
there's gonna be a lot of hype and a lot
of anticipation around this they drew
all this attention to this
for no reason but i would have several
questions for for mr biden as far as the
coven bill
you said that you want to reopen schools
and this cova bill is essential for it
but yet most of the money for that won't
be spent until 2022 what do you say to
parents mr biden that's one fair
question i think maria
yes yes for sure and i think there are a
lot of them
gentlemen good to see you tonight